hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round six of the
tata steel chess tournament 2021 uh
between jordan van forest and
david anton giharro and it's it's a very
long theoretical line so we're gonna
skip most of the opening
and uh that being said let's dive
straight into it uh
and also i have prepared the standings
for you so uh we're gonna check that out
as well to see what's happening uh
after six rounds so when forest opens
with
e4 uh we have e5 knight to f3 knight to
c6 and
bishop to b5 now we have the roy lopez
on the board
and a6 uh guihar goes for the morphe
defense uh we have bishop to a4
and knight to f6 we have castles and
bishop to e7 so this is all
a very standard stuff we've seen this a
million times
d3 and b5 pushing the bishop back bishop
to b3 and d6 and the white play c3
makes a room on c2 for the bishop also
will help if this pawn needs to be
pushed to d4
we have castles by black and now h3
taking away the g4 square from black
from uh black's pieces we have h6 and
now
a4 and we reached the position that was
played in 2020 last year in prague
masters
between ali and nikita vitigo that ended
in a draw
but in that game bishop b7 was played
however in this game we have bishop to
d7
uh and this bishop to d7 move shows that
giharo
definitely came prepared for this line
as this is the top move recommended by
the engine
and this is basically where our game
takes a new turn so
as of move 10 we have a completely new
game uh with
bishop to c2 by one forest and now b4
uh challenging the center center here of
of course if white captures then you
will no longer have support for your d4
push
uh so you're not interested in that we
have knight beat to d2
preparing the standard rookie one knight
f1 knight g3 move
uh rook the e8 uh preparing to shift the
bishop over to f8 so the rook
gains control of the center uh we have
a5 by white
uh and now bishop to f8 it seems like a
like maybe a dangerous move because
maybe the black could pick up the the
pawn
but for the moment as you can see it's
uh not all that possible you can't even
push the c
pawn to go after it so it is very safe
there
rook to e1 and now rook to b8
so preparing to capture will open up the
b file
and white decides to strike in the
center we have d4
uh b captures on c3 b captures e
captures and c
capture so now the tension in the center
has been resolved and the white keeps
his uh
a very nice center here uh and knight
the b4
by black going after the bishop on c2
and of course you do not want to trade
bishop for nike or so bishop back to b1
looks weird putting all of your pieces
on starting squares but
the bishop is actually very nice here
controlling
all of the squares the knight can move
to and uh
you know just just being placed on on
this long diagonal
so g6 gihar wants to shift the bishop
over to g7
and now rook to a3 the rook on a3
is an excellently placed rook so a very
nice rook lift
uh you're regarding a lot of stuff here
and also you can just shift to
wherever to b3 you could double up rooks
on e3 maybe if the knight moves you can
even go to g3
for some attacking purposes all
depending on what black plays
that did not happen uh we have bishop to
g7
uh black continues to put the bishop on
a on a battered better diagonal
and now nice to f1 white continues the
remaneuvering and black says
okay i definitely have to do something
so black
decides to trade pieces by also going
for a very nice rook lift
rook to b5 with the idea of guarding the
h5 square so this knight is coming to g3
and then black wants to trade off those
knights with knight to h5
so knight g3 and knight to h5 right away
we have knight captures and
rook captures on h5 and now maybe you
could run into some trouble
uh if this c6 pawn if this one gets the
c6 or maybe the a5 pawn becomes a little
bit weak
so here uh when forest uh takes care of
that by playing d5 so grabs more space
in the center also also cuts off the
rook here
uh we have c5 by black now creating a
wonderful pass pawn here
and now bishop to f4 uh you could go for
d
captures on c6 alpha but white says that
he prefers the greek
firm grip on the position and that this
pawn will not be an issue so bishop to
f4
goes after the d6 pawn that's an
undefended and now
bishop to b2 now attacking white's rook
here
uh we have rook 8 to e3 now doubling up
doubling up here rook to b3 is very
dangerous then you run into some ideas
like bishop
to a4 and then it's just uh well bad for
you
so instead after this bishop to b2 the
rooks are doubled up on the e file
and now queen to f6 black also needs to
defend now
attacks the bishop on f4 bishop to g3
and now black starts pushing his past
pawn
c4 and with the bishop guarding these
two squares could be very dangerous for
white
so queen to e2 here when forest prepares
this
e5 push and bishop to b5 now
preparing c3 which would also come with
an attack on the bishop
but white is maybe just a little bit
faster here here uh
we have e5 also very interesting is
bishop captures on d6 but we're not
going to go into it as there are so many
interesting lines uh that
we we're going to have to cover in this
game so uh
we have e5 here just uh attacking the
black queen
and now bishop captures on e5 we have
knight capture sunny
d captures on e5 and bishop captures on
e5 and now you can see that
everything has been traded off the
material is equal
but the problem is what can black do
here the problem is you cannot move the
queen if you move the queen
then the problem is uh well bishop to a1
you just move the bishop you keep
control of this diagonal you're
threatening rook captures here
which would end in checkmate uh there's
nothing uh
there's nothing that can be done here
even even though the bishop guards here
you cannot allow a triple capture here
because the bishop covers this
and then of course at the end of that
rook to h8 will be checkmate
so here you would have to play rook
captures on e3 but again after queen
captures on e3
not much better the threat is queen d4
followed by some checkmates here
and it's very hard to prevent this you
cannot do anything
if you capture with the rook to prevent
queen d4 then you allow queen captures
on h6 again with mate threats
so black is completely busted here so
unfortunately for david
anton you have to capture an e5 and he
does so with the rook rook captures an
e5
we have rook captures on e5 and now he
just continues pushing the pawn you you
cannot trade further if captures
captures captures and captures
it's uh terrible terrible end game for
black uh white
white is just uh winning here but we're
gonna reach a very similar position
later on so we're gonna show why so here
c3
just continuing to push the past pawn
and now comes queen to e3
vacating the c2 square and actually
allowing the c to move
and here we reach the position where now
black needs to
say okay uh we cannot allow this to go
any further we have to trade everything
here captures captures captures captures
and now uh c2 still doesn't work if you
go c2 now we reach a similar position
for example captures captures
and d6 in the white is completely
winning here there's nothing you can do
if you attack with the bishop then just
to rook attacks bishop pushing pushing
uh and if uh king to a f8 then the even
nicer rook captures on b5 captures and
the a pawn is winning now
uh there is of course nothing you can do
here also comes with
check so what you would have to do here
after all these trades uh in the center
you cannot go for c2 but you can play f6
and then maybe black can continue
fighting
uh getting his king a little bit closer
to the action but
it's still uh very unlikely for for
black to
to be able to survive this of course
with perfect play anything is possible
uh but after queen to e3 ghihara said uh
all right we're going to play c2 because
this is good for black
but it doesn't appear to be all that
great because here there is one move
that
really uh really is
great for for white and uh of course uh
von forest finds it
it's rook captures on h5 another thing
is you cannot capture on b1
like an in between move because rook
captures on b1 and then the knight is
also attacked captures captures and this
is just a winning position for white
so instead after rook captures on h5 we
have g captures on h5
and now comes uh uh bishop captures on
c2
this is what one forest played there
wasn't even a crazier line queen to d2
where you just allow this capture
and after rook captures then you're
attacking the knight and after knight to
d3
you uh capture with the rook on b5
captures captures and now again you have
a winning
position for white uh for example queen
a1 check you're going to have to play
king h2
captures here just a d6 and now black
queen will have to block but it's not a
problem d7
and you're just gonna have a very easy
time winning this position
if king f8 of course just queen d6 check
the king has to move and then it's uh
very very simple
so uh not uh not what was played but
after g captures on h5 we have the
immediate bishop captures on c2 by
manforest and this allows the david
anton
some counterplay he plays knight
captures on c2
with a nice fork here and now queen to
e5
saying okay we trade queens here
otherwise uh
you know i'm just gonna i'm just gonna i
have to give up a rook so
king the g7 defending the queen of
course you want white to capture so you
can improve the
activity of your king and now rook to e4
and here we reach a position where uh
you have to trade captures captures and
then black fights king f6 attacks the
rook
whatever rook captures king is gonna go
back but you still have two pieces for
the rook so black
black can still fight to this however
after rook to e4
uh david anton played bishop to d3
challenged the rook here but this move
of course completely blunders the game
and i'm sure you can see it but just in
case uh feel free to pause the video and
find the winning move for david anton
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations on spotting the
uh well peace grab in in two moves and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's
queen to g3 with check this is what evan
forrest played and it was in this
position that david anton uh resigned
the game
uh i haven't checked the uh time at the
end of the game so i'm gonna do that now
to see
uh how david anton was doing uh it's uh
yeah it's some three moves before time
control and he still had some
three minutes and 30 seconds on the
clock so it's not as if he were
let's say down to a few seconds he he
didn't have time to
uh spot this but you know uh
if no one ever blundered it there would
be no point in playing chess
so after queen to g3 he resigned and an
excellent win
win for uh one forest who climbs up the
ladder
so here of course if you move the king
just queen captures and it's a
completely winning
uh game for for white uh there's
absolutely nothing to do here the knight
is being attacked you're down the
exchange the
the d-pawn is gonna go up the board so
you're losing on all fronts
so yeah after queen to g3 check
davinaton resigned and
like i said we are going to show the
standings now so let's uh
check that out i don't know why they're
not showing let me just load
that uh oh oh that one
that's why it's a saved in a different
format there we go
so these are the standings after six
rounds uh
let me just fix that there we go
so uh after six rounds at the leader of
the tournament saw leader niels
grandelus who is playing just a
phenomenal
tournament if he can keep playing at
this rate
it's going to be definitely probably
probably his best
tournament ever uh then we have with
three and a half points a lot of people
pantalo hare krishna jordan van forest
fabiano corona magnus carlson anish giri
and alireza faruja
with three out of six uh andres penko
and radoslav
with two and a half young sister of duda
maxine bashar lagrave and aryanthari
with two points david anton guihara
after this loss and
uh still in last place with one and a
half out of six
uh alexander donchenko so those were the
standings and i hope you guys
enjoyed the game really a wild one uh it
could have gone either way but in the
end the one four has prevailed
uh so yeah we'll see what happens in
round seven uh i would like to thank
alima kasanova javier soler
uh gary kiran alan ferns and bupandra
sujitra for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of round seven of the tata
still checking up in your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend